7 billion people need to change the
conversation of what success looks like
it is not to make a billion dollars it
is to actually wake up in the morning
and be in a good mood attention is the
number one asset how about people in
here realizing that they have a job that
might pay them a little bit more than
something else but they hate it but
they're not willing to live in a more
humble home or drive a more humble car
and so they have a miserable job just to
pay for [__] that they have to impress
other people that they don't even like
how about that [__] conversation the
problem is everybody thinks you have to
make a billion and the problem is nobody
has humility to live a $100,000
lifestyle you need to figure out that
for you not what your parents think not
what I think not what the comments think
you